that was the first time that I ever  really felt like I connected with music  no I mean so that's the first time I  ever went to the beach it was so fun no  way that girl reminds me there's one  time  I'm very good it's really not bad that's  uh Kelly good I don't know what it is  it's delicious really sweet  can I get you some water no no I'm good  can I take your order on the salad can  you do spinach instead of arugula yes  thank you can I take your order I saw on  the menu you guys do a hamburger we do  on the children's menu and that comes  with waffle fries it does I'll take that  I suppose we could make one large enough  for an adult and a really great time  tonight  I had a great time I had a great time  too